hi everyone Sal here and I want to talk
a little bit about budgeting so at a
very high level a budget is a way of
keeping track of how much money you're
bringing in and how much you are
spending and the reason why you want to
do it is you at the most basic level
want to make sure you're not spending
more than you're bringing in but even
more you want to make sure that you're
spending it on the things that matter
more for you especially in the long term
so when you set up a budget and we'll
have other videos where we show examples
of this you're going to want to think
about the money that you're coming in so
this is often time going to be from your
paycheck maybe you have other sources of
money coming in you want to think about
that money after tax which can be
sometimes significant and then from that
you want to think about well where's the
money going to now a lot of folks will
talk to you about the 50 30 20 Rule and
this is it doesn't have to be exactly 50
30 20 but it's a nice framework to think
about which is 50 of the money that you
bring in maybe you could spend that on
your needs 30 you can spend on your
wants and 20 use that for savings now
what are needs and wants and actually
what qualifies the savings well needs
are things that you pretty much need you
need a place to live you probably need
some Transportation you need to eat so
for example your rent that would be a
need now you could debate how how much
of an apartment you might need but
wherever whatever you're paying for rent
is probably a need your groceries are a
need if you have to pay for example
insurance or lease or you're paying a a
note on a car those are all needs
now what are Watts well these are things
that you you might like but you you
don't need them necessarily to survive
for example you need to do groceries to
eat but you don't need to go to out to
eat at a restaurant that would be a want
and as we know it's a lot more expensive
to go to a restaurant than to get
groceries at the supermarket and cook
for yourself another want might be
you're going to a concert or you're
going to a movie or maybe going on
vacation or something like that that
would classify as a want and then
savings the number one reason why you
want it is you want to put some money
aside for a rainy day you want an
emergency fund where if for whatever
happens you had some medical expenses
that are you didn't expect happening or
maybe you have to help out a family
member maybe you have to transition your
work that you have something to live off
of you also want to put some money aside
if you're saving for a down payment on a
house or you're saving for some other
big purchase or you just want to save
for a retirement it it's important to
put that money aside so think about this
50 30 20 rule honestly the more that you
can put on the saving side of that the
better it shouldn't it doesn't have to
be only 20 but that gives you a nice
framework so for every thousand dollars
maybe you bring in after taxes 500 of
that for needs three hundred dollars of
that four watts two hundred dollars of
that for savings